okay part c suppose that z
equals uh negative root 12 uh
minus 2i okay how do we do this um
express z
in exponential form so better students
worked out what the modulus was by just
doing that pythagoras there
and then you could work out the argument
independently by taking
uh your cause and your sign and then
working out what the relevant angle was
now it was really sad that unfortunately
a lot of people
tripped up at that step with working out
the argument perhaps because you went
straight to
using tan if you have a think about it
this way when you do
sine over cos i might just write this up
here in red
sine over cos is just going to give you
remember
negative a half divided by negative root
3
on 2. what happens there well your 2's
are going to cancel
and your negatives are going to cancel
which gives you 1 on root 3 and so if
you go to your calculator and you do 10
inverse of this because this is um sine
theta on cos theta so this is tan theta
so to get theta you take 10 inverse
right
but we're cautioning you about this
method right at the very beginning right
you can see that this doesn't include
the fact because we cancelled it
that actually both of these are negative
right the negatives have just cancelled
so if you do ten inverse of one and root
three your calculator will hand you back
pi on six or indeed um you know 30
degrees if you're in degrees mode
and that is definitely not the angle you
can tell just by thinking about this
draw yourself a basic diagram
this is in the third quadrant there's no
way that pi on 6 which is a first
quadrant that's an acute angle
there's no way pi and 6 can be the
correct argument so that's how i got a
negative 5 pi
on 6. hence evaluate um the modulus of
one on z
and the principal argument of one on z
so you can see here what i did was i
hijacked the fact that i had done
the part one in exponential form so one
over z
is z to the power of negative one and
that's why you can see here i've got
this is
um the modulus four to the power of
negative one it's a reciprocal a quarter
and then with my uh argument over here
because it was negative five pi on six
when you raise that to the power of
negative one
the negatives cancel so it gives you 5.6
and that's that's it
no more having to go back into polar
form or doing any other working you've
already done enough
in part 1 to get you the solution in
part 2 without too much work
so we'll pause here and point out that
even though this is only
a question for part c several of you
were already taking a lot of extra time
and this only got worse as you got
further into the paper
by using inefficient methods or putting
a lot of additional working or not
drawing a diagram which made things just
a lot harder for yourself
so that's where you sort of cost
yourself time and when you went further
and further into the paper
you found you didn't have enough time
for later questions because you had
sacrificed that time
in the earlier ones okay we're up to
part d now so by writing the number i
in exponential form with its principal
argument
show that i to the i is a real number
that's what that um that's what that
weird notation means okay
so let's have a look at my solution over
here you can see that
over here i have written i first in
polar form just to make it really
obvious what's going on here right
you can see that this cos of pi over 2
is 0 and then sine of pi on 2 is 1 so
0 plus a single i that's what gives you
i and that's how i've written it
in exponential form and pi on 2 is the
principal argument
as the question has requested now the
reason why this is useful is because to
get to
i to the i power you can then just
raise both sides to the power of i and
because this is written in exponential
form you just get i
squared at the front by multiplying
those indices i squared is negative 1.
this is a real number this is a real
number you just got a real number
that's it so you didn't need to think
too hard again this is a place where
students spent a lot of time
you might have you know converted into
some other form and um sacrificed a lot
of the time that would have been useful
later in the paper
and this is all you needed to do the
question and by the way
this result here is just as an aside
here's a bit of an easter egg egg here
because i think it is just weird and
delightful that i to the power of i
is equal to a completely real number
only imaginary stuff mixed together and
you get only real stuff
i should point out there is a minor
caution here which is that i to the i
can equal
other real numbers and that's because
you can
you don't just have to express i with
its principle argument you could have
chosen a different argument
if the question hadn't specified and you
would have gotten a different number at
the end
but importantly it still would have been
real which is part of why i um
phrased the question an unusual way that
i did okay
we are on the last part of question four
now so this is a proof it says if z
equals
sine alpha plus i cos alpha show that
and then you've got this equation over
here on the right hand side so how do i
make this work
well as in all cases you need to pick
for your
result over here you need to pick a left
hand side or right hand side to start
with
and then move over to the other side
whichever direction you're going and i
think most people are pretty happy to
start with the right hand side because
it looks like a mess
and then move over the left hand side so
there are a couple of different ways you
can do this
firstly you can use some of your
properties of the conjugates
uh the complex conjugates of complex
numbers but you do have to be careful
when you prove when you use these
results in a proof
you really the burden of proof is on you
you've really got to show why these
things
are true so let's have a go at this
using conjugate properties which is
probably the fastest way
okay for starters um i start with this
this is just me quoting
the right hand side and then what i do
is i multiply by z
over z now this is a bit unusual because
you might think well how is this going
to simplify things
um on this first line here not much has
simplified at all you've got the z
outside of the oneplus z
you'll see why i didn't expand that in a
second and then on the denominator you
get z plus
z z bar but some of you might remember
that z
z bar actually is um a useful sort of
um result that you've seen before we've
actually
proven this result in class but i've i
wanted to prove this right you can't
just sort of pluck this out of nowhere
and you have to do this correctly and
those of you who took shortcuts around
trying to use this result
but didn't actually prove it some of you
got it wrong because you didn't prove it
so you
tried to rely on your memory this is not
on the reference sheet or anything like
that
so this is me multiplying a number by
its conjugate
you can see you just get this it's just
the expansion but you've got these ixys
which are the um they're the imaginary
parts right you can see they cancel plus
and minus just leaves you with x squared
plus y squared and that is
you know since the modulus of a complex
number is the square root
of x squared plus y squared that's why
you've got the square of the modulus
so that's why you can see me taking that
idea and substituting it in here
so in this case i actually know what the
modulus of z
is because i get told that z is not just
any number it's
sine alpha plus i cos alpha that might
have weirded you out a little bit
because the sine and the cos are
reversed from what you would normally
expect
but this is still importantly a number
on the unit circle it's just not where
you would normally expect it to be
so when you find its modulus sine
squared plus cos squared
that's one so this is nice because on
the denominator you get x plus one
uh this one plus z is the same as z plus
one so those two cancel
that gives you z as required now this is
a really clever way of doing it if you
knew to use that conjugate property um
but a lot of you might have said
how did you think of that right like
maybe maybe this result here z
z bar equals the modulus of z squared
didn't immediately rise to your brain
and that's fine there is a second method
it's a bit longer but it works just fine
what i'm going to do is turn everything
into polar form use my trigonometric
equations and identities to be able to
handle this so you can see
this is me rewriting the result that was
required to be proven
z equals 1 plus z on
1 plus z bar so you can see
there's z and there's z bar so
i've just taken that i've written it
over here this is my right hand side
and then i'm multiplying by this is the
conjugate
over the conjugate of the denominator
can you see that
you can see there's the plus i cos alpha
which
is the opposite inside to the minus i
cos alpha
you're going to get difference of
squares down here and even though
that's going to give us a bit of a mess
we can still work with it
and you can see i'm basically just
expanding left right and center what's
great about this is because
it does look like a mess i can actually
do a lot of simplification
because um you can see on the
denominator for instance here
you've got a sine squared plus cos
squared that appears which is the
pythagorean identity
that's equal to one and so you can see
that this one
and this one collect into this two and
you get a
similar situation happening on the
denominator the numerator
as well you get all of this cancelling
happening you can see that i've got
let's have a look at it
this term here this term here this comes
from
the square of this term over here
but because i want to get everything
sort of canceling out with each other
and i've got this i notice a sine
squared minus cos squared
i turn the cos squared again using the
pythagorean identity i turn that minus
cos squared into minus 1 minus sine
squared
right so that allows me to collect like
terms with these sine squareds
and you can see me then getting to this
point where i can factorize
and pull out the one plus sine alpha
which i also factorize
on the denominator because remember i
know i'm heading towards z
if i've said it once i'll say it a
hundred times you need to not just have
an eye on
what you're proving but also on your
destination what you're trying to get to
and so i know the denominator needs to
cancel out there is no denominator
in this result over here the left-hand
side that i'm trying to get to so that's
why
i kind of had faith that this 2 plus 2
sine alpha is somehow going to cancel
which indeed it does once you get to
your final line